[Music]
Hausa Gomez and finally I am here with
Octodad dadliest catch it is a
completely new standalone game from the
original Octodad and if anyone remembers
me even playing that game I was a long
time ago what the hell happened here
it's an a hilarious game about a dad
who's actually an octopus but he has to
complete everyday tasks without
revealing his cover that he's actually
not the pigs so we got the level wedding
bells and home sweet home
I think wedding bells would be kind of
fun to do I'm digging the music so far
it's pretty sweet make me wanna dance
what something wrong with my dance this
is not manly enough for you know one
minute work cuz that's more okay wedding
balance in which a normal human gets
ready oh okay so we're gonna head we
gotta get married without blowing our
cover Oh
move the mouse to control oh I was going
great so far
what if I need anyway okay remove the
cushions oh this is a tutorial I got
this I got no problem at all
there you go get the [ __ ] up oh yes okay
and the other what hmm these are
actually like get the [ __ ] Oh woops nail
it hit the male models or spacebar to
switch into leg mode okay so now we're
in leg mode this is how [ __ ] hit
swagalicious people walk oh you can tell
about the way you talk I'm whelmed it's
me [ __ ] yeah what's up in this door
okay I got a tie I don't know what I was
doing
you found a tie ties here no all right
there's I can already tell us a lot of
improvement from the original and it's
actually playable all right let's go in
here whoa all right what's going on
[ __ ]
is there a party here or what what am I
supposed to press this oh yeah twerking
twerking twerking twitch good best game
ever wonder how I got my bench with
these sweet-ass moves
did you see these moves there you see
these moves done Wow I call it the spin
and [ __ ] hit every what what happened
oh [ __ ] I did it again
get out here cake big chance can was I'm
fine and we're your oh that's what I was
impossible yeah got it's easy to get
distracted in this game okay what are we
shopping it's a banana peel which is
very appealing but we need to find our
soup [ __ ] low this game okay oh okay
I think we're just supposed to go in
here up and die oh man that's a nice
split how the hell I mean I wonder what
happens in the wedding night I've seen
enough hand-tied to know with ads go
I got my key to the hall door yeah after
that control yourself please for one
second job after that octave a la la I
it's not like I'm wearing a mask or
anything I like I literally look like an
octopus it would marry this man it's
beautiful though
yes hmm get it [ __ ] away from me chairs
I said get it I said get away from me
aah
god damn it find your boat that is not
your boat hi Octodad where you where'd
you go oh no not the banana peels
anything but the banana not okay all
right what do we got
Cthulhu what are you doing where am I
take your bow tie
let's go just moving your arm okay
nail that now that just gotta pick that
[ __ ] up put on your boat tie it at a
whole mirror but the [ __ ] is that octal
day oh here we go
okay okay gotta make sure we look
swagalicious I mean we have the moves
you see these moves yeah yeah look at
this dance ah [ __ ]
oh nice hey there handsome are you doing
you're looking fine sir
alright let's just put on a bow tie put
on our both tied that is I did it
somehow I have no clue how get past the
hole okay nailed it okay oh it's time is
it time to walk the aisle
get out of here presents I got a [ __ ]
to marry I mean oh the Hat of course you
can't get married without a top hat now
how do you put it on god damn it what
are you doing Paul don't [ __ ] that
there we go nailed it yeah yeah yeah I'm
coming I'm coming
no that way okay that yeah just give me
once one second hi I'm rod I just saw my
mate people are watching you if you'll
make a mess you'll get suspicious
oh [ __ ] okay uh don't worry I just had
some I'm a little nervous it's a big day
hi everyone Oh Jerry glad you could make
it
oh no my night don't mind that oh don't
worry oh come on after that get your
[ __ ] together I made are you doing
retrieve the ring from where my ass
how do I retrieve the ring ooh hello
girl how you do oh don't make me slap
you with my tentacle I'm just kidding
okay well the ring has to be over here I
need to be on my best behavior the ring
yes of course
oh I nearly how's easy hey what what's
the problem what do you want it there
you go
you should try to get as a bracelet no
kiss no kiss come on
they gotta make out a little bit is so
beautiful that's adorable
there be that's disgusting that is nasty
one of those horses doing what I meant
yeah okay this is just a prebuilt Alfa I
guess you could call it the game is
gonna come out I think even on
PlayStation 4 which is awesome I love
this song it's awesome yeah if you're
interested in this game I'll leave a
link to their website I think you can
subscribe to our newsletter so you know
when it's coming out Octodad
I'm pretty sure everyone knows he's
actually not the puss but they just
don't want to like be mean to him I
don't know dad
[Music]
nobody suspects that name do you see
these moves
[Music]
alright that was hilarious I love that
alright next episode we'll do the other
map and go ahead and leave it like if
you enjoyed this episode hit subscribe
to become a breath today and I'll see
you in the next one I'm doing shorter
episodes because I'm I'm away while
you're watching this
[Music]